I'm joined live by the parties Shadow
schools Minister Stephen Morgan first
time on the program good to have you uh
here thank you for coming in
um it looked like they had a bit of a
laughter a Deputy Prime Minister's
questions what do you think from the
from the room they did it was a bit
spikier compared with usual but I think
Angela Reynolds has a brilliant job
speaking up for our country uh now I
want to talk to you about housing policy
because this is
supposed to mean like it's getting out
to be one of the big Battlegrounds for
the next election
labor is quite controversially saying it
could build on the Green Belt just can
you just explain what that means what is
the green belt for our viewers it might
not understand well I think it'd be fair
to say that we've got a housing crisis
in our country and it absolutely is an
important issue that I hear on the
doorstep all the time in my own
constituency 2 000 people are waiting on
the council's waiting list for a home
the government Target used to be for 17
and a half thousand more homes in
Portsmouth in a really densely populated
city what key is set out today I think
is our intentions to say a lot more on
this in future that we need to make some
tough choices about reforming the
planning system and making sure we build
the homes that our country needs and I
think that's the right approach and as
he said he could be on the side of
businesses and on the side of Builders
not on the side of blockers the
questions about the Greenback though
right and the kind of buffer if you like
between the countryside and urban areas
that many people think is quite
important to stop you know an urban
sprawl you know Kirsten told me recently
that he would take on the nimbies but is
that a bit dismissive of some people who
might have genuine concerns about their
local area well it's really important
that people have their say in
communities are absolutely instrumental
in that and that's why we've got all
Take Back Control build that Lisa and
Andy's been setting out and she's been
engaging with communities up and down
the country you know but we've got to
find ways of building homes in our
country it's desperately needed the ways
that we live is changing and I think
we've got to make sure that local
authorities and communities have they're
saying these important decisions
you say communities had their say but I
mean that's not completely what you're
saying is it you're saying that actually
look it's important to build homes just
even on areas like the Greenbelt well
what I know about some of the
consultation around home building is
that sometimes the communities get
involved too late in the day and
actually we need to bring forward the
ways that communities have their say
much earlier on okay now teachers are
striking
I'm not I'm going to ask you what labor
would do but can I just ban the phrase
that you want to get around the table
because I feel like that's a given right
we know you want to get around the table
I want to know what you're going to say
when you get around the table so teach
us and turn down a 4.3 pay rise what
would labor do well the first thing to
say is that teachers are overworked
they're under huge stress and I think
they're undervalued and I think the
government have not done enough to
negotiate a deal you know I won't say it
but we certainly do want to see don't
say it come on Fair Deal what is the
Fair Deal then what is a fair well it's
really different everyone wants to see a
fair deal but everyone has different
definitions of what a fair deal is right
really difficult for us to say when
we're not in government we don't have
the information available to us but
we've got to listen and engage to
teachers they do tremendous
what keeps me awake at night Sophie is
the fact that so many teachers are
leaving the profession you know they've
joined the profession they've got the
chance to transform children's lives but
within a few years they leave because
they're demoralized the workload is too
great pays really important there are
other things as well and that's why I'm
talking to teachers on a regular basis
to find out what they'd want to see from
an incoming labor government and that's
my priority I mean I think what a lot of
teachers would like to say is more pay
right so what would labor give them more
pay well look at what we did in
government last time and we transformed
our nation schools pay Rose by 19 under
the last Labor government we completely
professionalized the teaching profession
and people joined that job it was a
brilliant job for people to do we want
to recruit more teachers so I'm
absolutely committed to talking to trade
unions to teachers and others I was in a
school this morning hearing what the
concerns are and I think more flexible
working is one of the answers to their
problems that they face I read an
interview with Rachel reads recently
where she was talking about how she
wouldn't send her children to private
school because she was saying that she
wants them to see the world as it is
what's your view on private education I
want to see every child in every part of
our country going to brilliant local
school of course that's a given right
but what is your view on private
education well we've been really clear
that we need to make some tough choices
about how schools are funded and we
think it's only fair that we end the tax
breaks that private schools enjoy that
would generate 2.2 to Berlin that would
go into the state sector and would do
some really transformative things to
improve outcomes for all young people do
you think that people who go to private
school don't see the world as it is
I think that parents make the choice
that they think's best for their child
it wouldn't be a choice that I would
make but ultimately that's the choice
that some parents do choose to make
um now I just want to talk to you a bit
about brexit because it seems to me that
Kirsten has been pretty Punchy about
breakfast about brexit today I said
breakfast there that's such a classic
classic brexit slip of the tongue there
and so to my colleague in King for
example he said he would be open to
renegotiation there's lots of things
that he wants to do including closer
trading so would labor see a much closer
relationship with the EU than the
current government then well as a
remainer I didn't want to see brexit
happen but I accepted the outcome of the
referendum I wanted to put that back for
people but lost the argument at the last
general election what key is set out is
obviously a five-point plan that we want
to break down the barriers for trade
want as close as possible relationship
with the EU I think that's the right
approach we need to move on we need to
make brexit work to smooth over the
edges and get the best for our country
you've ruled out we joined the EU you
said that you lost the argument the last
election and to have another referendum
you've also ruled out with Jordan the
single Market
I just wonder about the Customs Union
because it strikes me that look the big
issue that some would say with the
Customs Union she can't strike your own
trade deals but you know would you say
that the trade deals that we have
managed to get with other countries have
outweighed that that we could have as
part of the Customs Union
well I think what we're seeing with some
of the trade deals is there's not much
detail there at all and that's why you
know we want to see a labor government
to have a close possible relationship
with the European Community looking at
the Customs Union under a labor
government well we're really clear that
we want to see much closer relationship
with Europe we've set out a lot more
detail on our policies ahead the next
election
what about the Customs Union I know I'm
asking you to make you know you don't
want to give I mean it's not not my
brief of course what I want to do is to
make sure we hold the current government
to account for their failings on brexit
and we get the best possible deal for
our economy and create the jobs that our
country so desperately needs okay thank
you very much it's great to have you on
the program today thank you